You know that
sinking feeling when you noticed flashing
lights in the rearview look behind you?
Well, maybe it's not quite so sinking
when the drivers only two.
What did you say to her
when you got out of the car?
Asked her if she had a driver's license.
At that point,
she had her mouth full toothbrush.
So she wasn't too interested in the topic.
Yup. What's a toothbrush
in Rose Fern's mouth?
The siren noise was added later
so as not to scare Rose.
Okarche, Oklahoma, has a population
of about 1200 residents.
But after this video posted by police
chief for Smith went viral.
Well, thanks to Rose.
The world now knows Okazaki.
She got pretty famous overnight.
Relatives called the chief to come
watch those tests
drive the pink convertible
she got for a birthday.
The chief likes to post funny moments
on the department's Facebook.
I got a call from a hysterical lady
and she sounded really shaken up
that she drove through a parking lot
and seen this old man.
He just looked disoriented to her
a dummy with a Halloween mask in a pickup.
But Rose's story really got picked up.
You didn't even give her a ticket
for BWT brushing while driving.
I'm sure most parents would
be excited for their kid
to be brushing their teeth while driving.
She's starting young with her first brush
with the law
Ginormous.
CNN, New York.